♪ ♪
>> Laura: STARTING A NEW
SERIES TONIGHT WITH DRESSING
AMERICAN PROBLEMS.
WHERE WE BRING YOU THE ISSUES
LEFT UNSOLVED WHICH LEAVES YOU
AT RISK.
TONIGHT, RARE AND EASILY
PREVENTABLE DISEASES ARE MAKING
A COMEBACK.
THERE ARE MORE MEASLES CASES IN
THE FIRST THREE MONTHS OF 2019
THEN THERE WERE ALL OF LAST
YEAR.
AND YOU THINK THAT IS SCARY, A
MYSTERIOUS DISEASE RIGHT NOW
CAUSING PARALYSIS AMONG YOUNG
CHILDREN.
IT IS COLD AND FLEX MYELITIS AND
SIMILARITIES TO POLIO.
>> 12 TWOS 15 HOURS LATER, SHE
WAS PUT ON A VENTILATOR AND IT
WAS 100% PARALYZED FROM THE
SHOULDERS DOWN.
>> DIFFICULT FOR PARENTS TO
WATCH MY DAUGHTER BEING SO MUCH
PAIN AND NOT BE ABLE TO DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
>> HUNCHED OVER AND JUST IN
PAIN.
>> Laura: 20 ME NOW
DR. ANTHONY THE DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF INFECTION
IS DISEASES, WHAT IS CAUSING
MEASLES AND THEN WE GET TO ASM?
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH THE
MEASLES?
>> PARENTS ARE NOT VACCINATING
THEIR CHILDREN IN LOCALIZED
AREAS OF THE COUNTRY.
WHEN YOU GET THE LOOK BELOW A
CERTAIN CRITICAL LEVEL OF
PERCENTAGE OF COMMUNITY
UNVACCINATED TO, THEN WHEN
SOMEONE COMES INTO THE COMMUNITY
YOU WIND UP GETTING AN OUTBREAK.
TYPICAL EXAMPLE ROCKLAND COUNTY
IN NEW YORK AND IN NEW YORK CITY
AND THE JEWISH POPULATION.
SOMEONE WENT OVER TO ISRAEL AND
THEY HAVE A LOW VACCINATION RATE
ORTHODOX AND ISRAEL CAME BACK
INTO THE COMMUNITY AND BECAUSE
THE CHILDREN NOT VACCINATED, THE
UMBRELLA OF PROTECTION IN THE
COMMUNITY WAS LIFTED AND YOU HAD
AN OUTBREAK.
THAT IS WHAT IS GOING ON IN THE
COUNTY RIGHT NOW.
>> Laura: VACCINATIONS
CONTROVERSIAL IN SOME CIRCLES?
IF YOU GET TOO MANY VACCINES AT
ONE TIME A HIGH RISK OF OTHER
PROBLEMS.
>> Anthony: IT IS
MISINFORMATION, LAURA, THE
VACCINES ARE SAFE, EMMA MARK AND
MEASLES ARE SAFE AND THE MEASLES
VACCINE ONE OF THE MOST
EFFECTIVE VACCINES WE HAVE, 97%.
>> Laura: LET'S TALK ABOUT
ACUTE -- THIS IS TERRIFYING.
THESE ARE PARENTS THAT HAVE A
HEALTHY CHILD, ONE MOMENT TOTAL
PARALYSIS ON A VENTILATOR AND
THE NEXT, WHAT IS THIS?
>> Anthony: WE ARE NOT 100%
CERTAIN BUT IT IS HIGHLY
SUGGESTED THAT IT IS A
POST-VIRAL INFECTION.
AND POST VIRAL SYNDROME.
AND IT IS LIKELY A VIRUS THAT WE
ARE TRACKING THAT IS UP
POLIO-LIKE VIRUS.
IT ISN'T POLIO, FOR SURE IT'S
NOT POLIO BUT A CLASS OF VIRUSES
AND EPIDEMIOLOGICAL OCCURRENCE
OF THE OUTBREAKS OF THIS VIRUS
COINCIDES WITH THE OUTBREAKS OF
ACUTE --
>> Laura: A RESPIRATORY
INFECTION, ARE YOU MORE SO
ACCEPTABLE TO GETTING AND
AFFECTED BY THIS VIRUS?
>> Anthony: WHAT WE BELIEVE IS
THE VIRUS ENTERS THROUGH THE
RESPIRATORY TRACT.
MOST CHILDREN RECOVER WITH NO
PROBLEM AT ALL THAT REALLY A
CHILD THAT POST VIRAL SYNDROME
THE ACUTE FLACCID MYELITIS.
>> Laura: BUT YOU CAN'T DO --
EXACTLY, WE NEED TO PROVE WHAT
VIRUS IT IS.
WE THINK IT IS A D68'S SPECIFIC
TYPE OF VIRUS BUT WE DON'T KNOW
FOR SURE.
>> Laura: THE SYMPTOMS OF THAT
LEG OR ARM WEAKNESS, FACIAL
WEAKNESS, DIFFICULTY SWALLOWING
US, CHILDREN AFFECTING.
>> Anthony: 90% THE AVERAGE
A's FOUR YEARS OLD.
>> Laura: RECOVERY?
>> Anthony: THEY DON'T
NECESSARILY RECOVER COMPLETELY.
IN FACT SOME CHILDREN HAVE
RESIDUAL PARALYSIS OR
RESIDUAL WEAKNESS WHICH IS